why would I point out to you there's a
bit of Anarchy too I want the extension
to students of a dream products is that
the way you make a question interesting
or tricky is that you take it as a topic
and then you see will in what ways can i
connect this to another time okay now in
my experience people look at this and
they just freaked out because they've
never seen something like this before
but that's the whole point of
mathematics that the super power of
mathematics is seen through the exterior
we may look different through the core
of what something actually is due to its
essence so you see they're actually very
very similar they're bound by the same
principle okay so have a look at the
situation with me I'm gonna take a seat
in a second actually something to draw
others you've got this big triangle here
right and it's been subdivided in this
following unusual way they're taking up
well let's do I guess record norwalk
tonight oh they're taking this
perpendicular this paper because this
replica and that they're using that to
look at a whole series of links you're
going to see this up so use come out in
the bin right then there are other
schedule okay so luckily with you what
they do to begin with is they hold your
hand and they say look just don't get
overwhelmed by the infinite pneus of the
of the question to start small find the
length of the interval be be in here
right that's all you need to do and
hence show that the length of and then
they give you some other disability fun
so have you go in the unit of the
diagram yeah and we need some diagrams
here let's start by just drawing this
triangle in which cleanup inhabit
because
triangle at bd's is right so simple
diagram we are looking for this length
over here on the left-hand side this is
what we're after so putting a are meant
to take there for us how do we find this
interval well you can see by the
question it's going to have something to
do in sign if you know you know what
theater is so that we just got to kind
of believe that into question right what
is it the connects theta at this side on
the side thank you it's just regular
site theta right because you're in a
riding with training so i'm going to say
sine theta equals opposite on my phone
so that's beating on six times right so
the first time discretion is just what
is beating so i have an intern okay
that's good that was the easy part but
then what they want us to do is to use
their result hence use that result they
get to the length of this side here so
this is a couple of triangles away right
now to try and make a little clear on
what's going on this theta that we found
is training there is a theta in every
triangle that's on the diagram it's not
entirely the hundred percent obvious
until you get down to brass tacks and
try and work out what's happening right
so goodbye yeah I'm not good ok have a
look at that triangle there right if it
don't zoom in a little bit so this is
this um this abd triangle that I'm
talking about here this this is the one
that we drew just a second ago right so
there it is now you can see we actually
know some stuff about the other angles
there namely that over here you've got
that 90 degrees that's let me do since
we're calling this theta that means that
the last remaining angle abd is what's
its size yeah it's 19 take away it's the
compliment do you agree so I'm going to
put this guy in here as 19 take away
however we also know that a be like this
big angle here ABC that whole angle is
90 do you see that so if you've got the
complement of 90 nestled in here and
that whole angle ABC equals 90 degrees
then what must the other side babe yeah
I've got theater here right do you see
that so therefore I've got feet up all
over again and I already know that this
length in here Biddy let's use this this
length in here we just said that that
was six sine theta right so now think
about in this triangle right so all of
this has to do with in triangle a big
today I really should have written that
first so now I'm going to look at the
next tribal over this is bd8 do you see
this is one of the reasons why it's
important to state which triangle you're
in because I'm going to have three of
them or flying around right so in Vee I
invoke the same kind of lean right I'm
gonna say design theater again but it's
a different pair of science right what
other side's women names it's desi it's
the opposite right opposite on
hypotenuse because there's the optic
angle opposite the right angle right so
I'm going to say that is when we just
say d e or six sine theta right so now I
know what day it is it's just going to
be six sine squared so this is good this
is promising because when you have a
look back at what the question was
asking us you can see it's like look I
need to just go one more step I need to
go walk was there but this is sure I
can't just say oh cool it looks like
that and you should demonstrate how do i
get there what am I going to do I've got
to go through this same process right so
I'm going to do the same thing up here
knowing that I have got clear here where
is the complement of theta in this
strangle empty yeah where is he baby
it's right up there in the top so I'm
going to put that in blue so this guy
here that thin one that is and
any take away Thea should say 90 degrees
you get the idea okay now be now I've
got 90 a clean up but again I've got
that seem right angle here that i
mentioned before right so that means
that this entire angle here should also
be 90 degrees yet do you see it so
therefore let's get rid of those guys
that means i can tell you that this guy
is Theta link here are you right Eddie
following so now I can do one last time
and I can say in triangle what for
triangle my energy and okay big EDF
again i'm going to say Santino and again
it's going to be opposite on like what
nice but it's a different opposite and a
different hypotenuse the opposite is
here and the hypotenuse is yeah d which
we just established with six sine square
theta so now this is the result they
were asking for so I ended up like so
hey happy with that so this is just some
simple geometry okay it's like hey right
angle triangles I did this back in the
Unites it's not complicated